There's one area we should circle back on,
learning about the company itself.
It's extremely important to research
the company you're interviewing with before your interview.
As we mentioned before,
you'll likely get asked about why you want to work for the company,
but you are also likely to get asked about what you know about the company's products,
especially in the area you would be working in.
Near the end of the interview,
you could also utilize the information you've researched,
they'll come up with detailed questions for the interviewer
themselves in order to avoid asking generic questions.
Let's take a quick look back in the job posting from before.
One of the first things to know about how a company
describes itself is in its commitment to community.
This would indicate to me that I should check out
some of their community initiatives they do.
The next paragraph discusses more about their focus on transportation.
Note that this is broader than the most common area they're known for in ride-sharing.
Know who they consider themselves competitors with.
Realizing that they are about mobility and transportation as
a whole means there is a wide range of companies they see as competitors,
as opposed to what you might expect.
This is not included in the job description,
but while this course was being developed,
Lyft had recently acquired
a bike-sharing company and had announced plans around scooter-sharing as well.
That was fairly easy to gather from some research of press releases, news,
and blog posts, but it's important way to show that
you're knowledgeable about and care about the company.